Uh uh 5
What is it, especially with the surname
Naju and the capital of the house for free,
oh yeah, your face is also very young, so stay healthy and pretty.
I
don't think it's a problem with my phone, I'm sleepy [Music] I don't think it's a problem with the phone
Fully adult artists spit out the inside
and take a bit of self-portrait Uh
yeah yeah, I've tried it with several artists in the meantime, but
that person comes up with an ok cut, but the
artist
Jessica's only daughter, Illinois etch and church don't eat kimchi, so they don't eat kimchi at the church.
That's really good g
[Music]
Butts are down uh uh
monster I think I'll really think about it now
[music]
ah
[music] uh